epic is suing apple after fortnite gets
removed from the app store
spider-man miles morales will deliver a
complete story and red dead online rolls
back a potentially game-breaking
patch i'm lucy and these are the biggest
gaming news stories for thursday august
13th
[Music]
epic games is now suing apple
it all started when epic made v-bucks
cheaper in fortnite across
all platforms up to 20 off the previous
price
now this is a permanent change it might
not feel too different if you're playing
on pc and consoles
but the price change was really intended
for fortnite's mobile versions
so that epic could undercut the apple
and google play stores
now when you try and buy v bucks on ios
or android you'll be given
two options buying directly from epic or
buying through the device's built-in
store
only the direct purchase from epic has
the new cheaper price
this is epic's way of getting around
apple and google royalties
something the developer has been very
vocal about in the past
apple responded almost immediately by
pulling fortnite from the app store as
of recording this video it's still
available on google play apple issued a
statement
today epic games took the unfortunate
step of violating the app store
guidelines that are applied equally to
every developer and designed to keep the
store safe for our users as a result
their fortnite app has been removed from
the store
epic enabled a feature in its app that
was not reviewed or approved by apple
and they did so with the express intent
of violating the app store guidelines
regarding in-app payments that apply to
every developer who sells digital goods
or services
the fact that their business interests
now lead them to push for a special
arrangement does not change the fact
that these guidelines create a level
playing field for all developers
and make the store safe for all users we
will make every effort to work with epic
to resolve these violations
so they can return fortnite to the app
store shortly after
epic games has filed a lawsuit against
apple
it calls attention to the exorbitant 30
cut that apple takes from app store
purchases
comparing it with the three percent
average that's available to developers
selling software
on a mac or macbook it states that the
anti-competitive consequences of apple's
conduct
are pervasive arguing how central mobile
devices which are subject to the 30
fee are to people's lives they say that
these devices are unfairly restricted
and extortionately taxed by apple
the consumers who rely on these mobile
devices to stay connected in the digital
age
are directly harmed epic says it's not
seeking compensation for the damage it's
incurred
but is instead doing this to end the
monopoly that apple is working to
maintain
we'll obviously keep you updated as this
is
huge there have been a lot of questions
about what spider-man miles morales is
going to be when it launches later this
year so director brian horton
has taken to ew to reveal some more
details
it's not a full sequel to 2018's marvel
spider-man but it is a complete
stand-alone game
brian horton said we really are
completing this heroes coming of age in
our game
it's a complete story when we started
crafting it we realized that
with a little bit more of a compact
storytelling style we could tell a very
emotionally impactful story
that would fit really well as an
experience that would take spider-man 1
and miles morales and do justice to this
character
horton also revealed that miles
bioelectric and invisibility powers in
his suit
represent his character too spider-man
miles morales is launching this holiday
in the same window as the ps5
whenever the heck that is going to be
sony please
give us a release date rockstar have
rolled back a game breaking patch for
red dead online
red dead online's biggest new content
drop was the naturalist update letting
you observe and document nature in the
game
but the patch that followed the
naturalist update broke nature instead
animals weren't spawning horses were
flying and alligators were just
raining from the sky for five days the
game was going nuts and was basically
unplayable but it's finally being rolled
back to its july 28th version
the naturalist content is still
available and the game should now run
as intended so we can all go back to
pretending to be david attenborough
as we were before tomorrow right here on
youtube.com
gamespot we're going to be premiering a
brand new show called generation
next all about the ps5 and xbox series x
every week we're going to be breaking
down the biggest news stories about next
gen consoles and
boy what a week to start it's been quite
the week
uh but we'll also be talking to
developers as well as just getting
really excited about the new console so
make sure you join us
every friday we'll see you then
[Music]
you